you can't really be a cowboy if you
don't take care of cows to see the
future of America Modelo looks not to
its coast but to its heart it's there
where we found a place fighting for
bettering the reality of working in the
feed yard is it's not as glamorous as
working on a big ranch and being the
Marlboro Man no matter what the weather
is you got to saddle up and be out there
taking care of the cattle these guys are
tough I mean they're just they're just
plain tough vamos todos dias de ovando
TUV endows stay alight on also
e-commerce a notice and almost achilles
Corrales vamos todos los cinco that was
no para randy retama a keep the cattle
business is an up and down business and
that's why I moved to Garden City was
because my family wasn't gonna be able
to generate enough income so one of us
had to leave to come out and just be
another person that moved into town and
able to move up into a good company
those are things that I'm happy about
take okie okie dokie Vania de de Mexico
leukemia or unos que aprendido pokeo de
la de la vida que lo único que quiero es
de Sciglio al al mundo que tienes una
voz yo pills okay una dos sorry I'm a
[ __ ] para todo el beneficial at table
mundo the cowboy way it's integrity its
honesty it's finishing what you start
the whole thing has to work together
we're feeding the world from here
[Music]